hello my name is bill ozanic i'm the eh
s manager here at the milliforce signal
belfon site
today i'll be discussing with you some
aspects of safety in your analytical
laboratory
first thing we want to talk about are
safety gloves there are several
different types of safety gloves you'll
find in your lab
most common gloves are your nitrile
gloves these are
general chemical resistant gloves
they're good for general purpose
uh for various types of chemicals
your work with more hazardous materials
like
caustics acids or more severe solvents
you want to go to a heavier style glove
which is built for
more more hazardous conditions and more
protection
for the for the user
if we're working with sharps i.e needles
and or ampules when you're breaking the
ampule open
you want to go to a cut resistant glove
these particular gloves
are a kevlar back with a nitrile coating
for extra grip
please check with your safety officer
for what gloves are recommended for your
actions
now i'd like to discuss the proper
donning and doffing of your chemical
gloves
done your gloves is pretty
straightforward
you want to make sure the gloves fish
you nice and snug
the better fit for your gloves the more
dexterity you're going to have
now once the chem once the gloves are
contaminated
doffing the gloves is a little more
critical you don't want to get your
hands contaminated while you're taking
your gloves off so the proper to remove
your chemical gloves when they're soiled
grab the palm carefully pull the glove
off of your hand
once that hand is free you go in behind
the other glove
both gloves inside out
and you can safely dispose of your
gloves in your waste container
bill where is the best place to throw
gloves away when they're
contaminating those contaminated gloves
every lap should have
a contaminated glove receptacle your
waste manager should provide that for
you
so all of your gloves that are soiled
and contaminated with any chemicals can
go
be disposed of properly
so before entering any chemical
laboratory you need to protect your eyes
safety glasses are what we use to do
this there are several different styles
of safety glasses your most common type
are your disposable safety glasses
they're available at any
safety warehouse or distributor if
you're working with more hazardous
materials
you want you might want to consider
using a safety shield
this fits over your head and over top of
your glasses this is used for when
you're working with more aggressive
caustics
and or solvents if you have a
prescription your safety manager can
provide you with
prescription safety glasses just like
these
i'll say the prescriptive safety glasses
have to have permanently
fixed side shields and are rated for
strike resistance
you'll see there's a little mark on the
side that those are actually
strike resistant glasses
again please check your safety officer
to provide you with the correct glasses
for your situation
next thing i would like to talk about is
your protection for your body
and your clothes entering a laboratory
you want to make sure you're wearing
some sort of protection for yourself and
your clothes
and i.e a lab coat there are different
styles of lab coats you can have a
launderable lab coat like i'm wearing
or a disposable lab coat like this
disposable lab coats are nice because if
they do become soiled they can be
disposed of just like your disposable
gloves
in your waste stream just like your uh
the way your safety manager will direct
you uh
depending on what they're contaminated
with your reusable lab coats will need
to be laundered
typically we will wear these for a
couple of days if they don't get any if
they don't get soiled with any chemicals
as soon as it becomes soiled with
chemicals though it now needs to be
laundered
so you make sure you separate that from
the general uh waste
or general um uh
clean and dirty laundry and make sure
that the
provider for your lab coat knows that
that lab coat has been soiled with with
uh chemicals so they can treat it
properly if it becomes too soiled with
chemicals it might need to be disposed
of
so if you get if you have a large amount
of material on you that lab coat even if
it is launderable
would probably be need to be disposed of
is fit important for a lab coat too bill
so uh your lab coat should be a proper
size
for you uh wearing a live clip that's
too big could possibly
uh awkward working with so you might
want to get a lab coat that's pretty
simply about the same size as a typical
jacket you would wear
out in the cold weather
this time i would like to talk about
proper chemical storage
all chemicals need to be stored in the
correct cabinets several cabinets are
are shown right here a flammable cabinet
is for your flammable materials
i.e solvents alcohols and other
flammable materials
your flammable cabinet all need to have
secondary containment so if you do have
a
chance of a spill inside the cabinet the
material is contained
all of your materials need to be labeled
properly so you don't have any
question of what is inside your
flammable cabinet
flammables must be kept separate from
your acidics
those will be stored in an acid cabinet
acid cabinets are typically have a
phenolic liner and a phenolic
construction rather than a metal
construction
because of the corrosive nature of the
acids again secondary containment and
proper labeling for all of your
materials
all of your acid bases need to be kept
safe need to be kept separate
so you have another corrosive cabinet
very similar to this one
to store your bases in
one last cabinet to talk about is we
need to separate our toxic materials
from our flammables
typical in an analytical chem laboratory
we're going to find
fluorinated materials ie dichloromethane
methylene chloride
or chloroform any chemical that has
designated a
toxin cannot be stored with a flammable
please check with your eh
s manager for proper storage of your
chemicals
one of the main safety features in any
chemical laboratory is a fume hood
the fuel one consists of a few different
parts one of the most critical parts
is the safety sash safety sash is used
to keep
any chemicals that could potentially
splash on you away from you as you're
working it we'll demonstrate that here
in a minute
the airfoil part of the hood when the
sash is all the way down
allows the airflow to accelerate in and
sweep any hazardous fumes
or odors or any type
of vapors out of the hood
well you can really hear it when you
open it up
that's one way of telling that the hood
is actually functioning the other way to
tell the hood
is functioning is actually to use i'd
like to use a chem wipe
and you pull it to the back of the hood
and you actually see that the chem wipe
is getting swept towards it don't let it
go because your
maintenance guys won't like that but
make sure you can tell it is working
the alarm you hear is another safety
feature on most fume hoods
the alarm is set for the appropriate
height of your sash when you're working
the fume hood
you should not work with the fume hood
all the way open
working with the fume hood all the way
open lowers your face velocity
and you potentially have uh vapors and
fumes leave the fume to come back at you
when you're working with the hood your
sash will be set at the proper height
for your calibration for your fume hood
so as you're working with it
you can place your arms inside the hood
still have the sash between you
and the hazard and adding another level
of protection
the other thing all fume hoods need to
be serviced
and calibrated on a regular basis per
ocean
every fume hood needs to have an
inspection record on it so if your
la your laboratory area is inspected by
osha they will want to make sure that
your hood has been
properly calibrated and certified that
is working properly
for the osha regulator and it looks like
this little alarm also is
tested as well correct as part of that
the alarm is also calibrated and tested
as per that same inspection
okay so how about handling things under
the fume hood so
i have the hood open because we're not
working it right now a couple things
also to know about working in a fume
hood
we can actually shut that arm off there
we go
so if you're actually in your fume hood
you don't want to use your fume hood for
storage
however if you have some common
materials that you're using on a regular
basis
they can be can be put in the fume hood
as long as you keep them off of the
floor
so if you get the proper face velocity
across the lower surface of the hood
you can set up some other device in here
to to put some things in there like some
of your glassware that you're going to
be using every day
and some of your other storage again
everything that's in your hood needs to
be properly labeled so everyone knows
what is actually inside the fume hood
and you only want to keep stuff in there
that you're going to be using on a
routine basis
everything else should be kept in this
proper storage location
so what about like when um how far back
from the opening of the hood should you
handle the chemicals when you're working
in there
okay so when you're actually handling a
chemical this lip in here is
part of a moat system so if you do have
a chemical spill it keeps that from
flowing out of the hood
so you want to keep your materials about
six inches away from the face of the
hood
that make sure you get proper velocity
around the hook around the device or
around the material
if you can sweep all the vapors and
fumes away from you so if you're working
too close to the lip
it's possible that you could have be
exposed to fumes from what you're
working with
correct so if you have if you have your
material up too close to the face
two things could happen one you could
actually the material can
can accidentally be
excreted from the hood or come out of
the hood or you can actually get it to
spill on you
if something would happen if something
would spill and or uh
the splash on you so you want to make
sure you keep your material inside your
hood
keep your sash at the proper height so
it's comfortable for you to work in
again you would have your proper gloves
off your handling materials but the fuel
is probably one of the key pieces of
safety equipment in any laboratory
now i'd like to talk to you about proper
chemical labeling all the materials in
your lab have to be labeled
with the ghs labels ghs stands for the
global harmonization system
this is the only approved system for
proper chemical labeling that is
available today
and on a ghs label you're going to find
a couple of different aspects
you're going to find the proper chemical
name
you're going to find the proper chemical
symbols you're going to find the proper
cast number
and some particular information about
your chemical
this all comes from the uh the um the
sds
or safety data sheet that is designed
for that that is basically aligned to
this chemical
so check your your safety data sheet and
everything will match
this is actually this system were was
designed for
uh globally as in it was used worldwide
so all the
no matter where you go in the world
these uh these symbols
all mean the same thing so we're on this
bottle bill this is dichloromethane so
that first symbol looks kind of
interesting
what does that mean so that's a toxin so
that is the toxic
uh so that the the silhouette of the
person with the
uh kind of exploding heart is this is a
symbol for toxins
uh the exclamation point is a another
symbol for
other uh as other um toxic
natures of it and it'll be listed in the
uh on the sds
and then there's something about colors
too with these labels a lot of your
other labels will have the
nfpa color coding on it for
health flammability reactivity
and other so depending on what material
you have
your nfpa ratings are separate from the
ghs but they can
be used combined to make sure as it on a
label like this one for methanol
that we have the health for methanol as
a two the flammability is a three
because it's very flammable
it's a non-reactive material and it has
no other designation
some of your other materials like uh
your oxidizers or your acids or bases
will have some other designations on
them in the white box
depending on what type of material they
are please check with your ehms manager
and your safety data sheet for the
particular chemical you're working with
and as an aside too just a tip for uh
for you guys in the laboratory these
labels are available
from various vendors so you can purchase
them and then use them to label the
chemicals in your laboratory so that you
have nfpa and ghs labels on them
next thing i would like to talk about is
hazardous waste in your chemical
laboratory
all of your hazardous waste needs to be
controlled and needs to be disposed of
properly
before disposal you have to collect it
so some examples how we collect our
waste here
is our waste solvents are collected in a
satellite accumulation container
that is properly labeled our lcs
supply all the waste from the lcs
are manifolded and it flows into the
container
a vent line keeps it from over
pressurizing
these have these are allowed to be
left on site for a reasonable amount of
time or until they're full
then they have to go to your waist
accumulation area
once they reach your race accumulation
area depending on the size of your site
is how long they're allowed to be there
some of the other wastes we have they're
typical in a lab our contaminated
glasses
so you've got okay vials bottles things
like that yep okay
contaminated plastics pipette tips you
would have
exactly well plates if you use those
right and gloves
okay we've got a purple bucket to match
up for the purple glow we do
we do all of your waste streams need to
be kept separate
uh all your waste streams need to be
disposed of properly your uh your
waste manager or your environmental
health and safety manager will be
working with
a disposal company to make sure that all
of your waste gets disposed of
for the proper regulations for the size
of your lab please check with your
eh s manager for proper disposal of any
materials that you have in your lab
thanks bill and i also like the way you
guys did the hplc so you don't have to
worry about
waste going into a bottle that overflows
it just goes right into these um
lines here that go right into this into
the waste buckets that's good
and i just have a question what i see
this guy here
what's this little tote thing for so
transporting any materials around your
lap should always be in secondary
containment
these totes are used for transporting up
to a gallon of material
so you can fit a gallon jug in here so
uh if this is this gets dropped
you have a good chance of the any of the
material that could be come out of the
bottle that got cracked it also creates
a nice bumper
so if it does hit the ground there's
less chance of the bottle to get broken
but as you're transporting anything in
your chemical laboratory you should use
secondary containment as a good practice
one of the other safety devices you
should have in your laboratory is a
spill kit
spill kits are used in case you have a
small spill in your lap and needs to be
cleaned up
spill kits should be placed where
they're very conspicuous i.e on a hook
like this one
so you know if it's missing all of your
spill kits need to be inspected
on a monthly basis per osha and they all
need to make sure
that all the contents are actually uh
available to
for in the in the kit for your spill
now that one's sealed up bill so like uh
how would you inspect something like
that precisely
this is actually sealed because if we
know if the seal is broken
then something's been taken out of it
okay so if you have one that is not
sealed
all the contents need to be inventoried
on a monthly basis
for the osha regulation that makes sense
anywhere you're working with a chemical
you should have an eye wash
eyes are the most susceptible part of
the body so if you do get splashed
you want to be able to flush that out
properly
this is an example of an eye wash we use
here at the site
point to use it you would actually swing
it into position and you can push on it
and it will
whoa okay get your hair wet too
when you have when you have a chemical
exposure neat and tidy is is the last
thing you're worried about
you want to make sure you flush your
eyes and your face properly
uh all your eye washes and safety
showers need to be inspected
monthly and then a typical good practice
is to have them done by an annual
inspection
with by a third party uh just to make
sure that everything is
functioning properly okay then
if you do actually get something in your
eye how long
should you wash for so typical flush
good practice will be 15 minutes
of steady flow over your eyes and your
face to make sure you've got uh
the material flushed out and if you have
an exposure where you're using a
uh an eye wash you really should go see
a medical professional
once uh you've got the the flushing
after 15 minutes you really should go
see a medical professional
bill thanks for that explanation on the
eye wash i just noticed there's this
green
tape around the area by the eye wash
what is that for
so all your eye washes need to be fully
accessible at all times
so you a best practice is to tape off
the area
so that nothing gets placed in uh that
could interfere with your access to an
eye wash
because if you're exposed your eyes
might be compromised you might not be
able to see
you might know where the the sink is so
you can get to the sink but you don't
want anything in your way
so you can get the eye wash into
position and be able to turn it on
because you might not you might be by
yourself in the lab right so you have to
find your way over so
okay thanks for that explanation no
problem
a sister device to your eye wash is your
safety shower safety showers and eye
washes sometimes come in separate units
like we have here
or they come in a uh a unit basically
connected together where the eye wash
and safety shower are all in one
that's important normal way that the
newer systems are put in
again with your eye wash that system
needs to be tested on a monthly basis
and should be tested annually by a third
party to make sure it's working
correctly
so please work with your ehs
professional make sure your eye watch
safety showers
are working as their as designed
one of the other common devices you're
going to find in your lab for safety is
a fire extinguisher fire extinguishers
should be located in a convenient
location it should be probably should be
labeled
so they're easily found and they should
be inspected uh
annually by your fire uh provider
or and monthly by one of your safety
professionals
a fire extinguisher is used only in the
situation
to save yourself if you're not
comfortable with using a fire
extinguisher to put out a large fire in
your in your laboratory
it is not required it should be only
used for putting out small fires
and to get you to safety if you have a
fire in your laboratory
you should get up get the safety and
notify
your safety professional and or your
security force immediately
if you do not have one on site please
call 9-1-1 and get your fire department
there as soon as possible
so bill i noticed that it's near the
door is that
of the desired location or is that just
happens to be in this lab
near doors there's a very common place
for them because you're using them to
exit the building typically you want to
make sure you have it available
in case your way to the exterior of the
building is blocked by the fire
and if you do have to use it what's the
proper like other steps you need to do
to use it properly
sure proper steps for using a fire
extinguisher
is very common very simple we call it
the pass system
when you get your fire extinguisher p
stands for pull we're going to pull the
pin
you basically twist this to release the
safety seal and then the pin comes out
you want to release the the hose
aim at your a at your at the base of
your fire
squeeze the handle when the pins remove
the handle will squeeze and release the
agent
and then you will sweep back and forth
at the base of the fire until the fire
is out
so pull aim squeeze and sweep
pass pass a good roll
uh a good rule would be to
have an annual training on how to use a
fire extinguisher because you never know
when you're going to need it and it's
good practice for everyone to have that
at least once a year so they're familiar
with how their fire extinguishers work
and they know how to use them in an
emergency situation
okay that's great thanks bill thanks
very much so
um any final party words for our um
analytical labs out there
my final parting words for any
analytical labs uh
i am of the uh rule of thumb that
a a clean lab is a safe lab so keeping
your lab neat and tidy
all of your materials in their proper
location all of your materials labeled
uh we'll make sure that you're well on
your way to having a safe laboratory
uh for your area and uh i wish everyone
good luck thanks very much bill
hello and welcome to this webinar
thank you for joining in today my name
is ingrid heinger
and today we'll be discussing reference
materials and what differentiates a
certified reference material
from any other analytical trait
today i'm representing the company
milipor sigma
i'd like to further explain that the
life science business of
merck in darmstadt germany operates as
milipro sigma in the u.s and canada
this same company is known as merck kdaa
throughout the rest of the world
these pictures help to illustrate that
reference materials impact daily life
the water we drink the food we eat the
air we breathe
the drugs we take through calibration of
measurement systems
validation of methods and quality
control programs
reference materials ensure accuracy in
testing
and its testing which helps to ensure
all of what we see
so let's start with testing and
reference materials
on a basic level what does testing mean
testing
is the comparison of an unknown sample
with something known
and this something known is the
reference material
testing can be qualitative or
quantitative qualitative tests typically
confirm
the identification of an analyte or its
presence or absence in a sample
other qualitative tests can confirm
confirmation of physical properties
like conductivity or color
quantitative tests determine the actual
amount of an analyte in a sample
like the concentration of pesticide in a
can of tomato juice
other quantitative tests can for example
determine the potency of a drug or
cannabis strain
or the cut-offs for drug of abuse in a
patient's blood sample
the testing required to certify a
reference material
focuses on the material and its
impurities
for the material that's the identity
product purity
mass percentage of content and physical
properties
for the impurities those are water
residual solvent
and organic or inorganic impurities
typically the result of the
manufacturing
or purification process for the raw
material
the production of a reference material
is a key activity
for the improvement and maintenance of a
worldwide coherent measurement system
reference materials with different
characteristics are used in measurements
such as calibration quality control
proficiency testing
and method validation certified
reference materials are also used to
confirm
or establish metrological traceability
to conventional scales
i will come later to explain a little
bit more about what triological
traceability means
to be comparable across borders and over
time
measurements need to be traceable to
appropriate and stated references
now let's take a look at the different
types of reference materials
generally there are five different
quality grades of reference standards
available on the market
as this high requirement shows the level
of certification
and traceability requirements increases
for each higher level
at the top level are the primary
standards
the primary measurement standards are
produced by national metrological
institutes
like nist in the us or gsc in europe
these authorized bodies are recognized
by the national governments as the sort
of truth
considered to provide the highest level
of accuracy
and traceability in a reference standard
in the pharmaceutical world you have
primary companion standards produced by
the pharmacopoeia
like the usp or the european
pharmacopoeia
while not necessarily a government
entity these harmocopiers work closely
with government agencies
and are legally recognized in many
countries as providing the highest level
of accurate and traceable reference
standards
for use in pharmaceutical monograph
testing
whereas national governments give
standardization to the top level
specific iso requirements provide
standardization for the next two level
certified reference material and the
reference material
these iso requirements include iso 70 or
34 17025 and isoguide 31
reference materials producers must meet
these iso requirements to manufacture
crms or albums
within iso which is the international
organization for stenarization
crms are considered to provide the
highest level of accuracy
uncertainty and traceability to an si
unit of a measurement
reference materials fall one level lower
as they are manufactured
and tested to a level less demanding
than that of a crn
iso guidelines also prescribe that a crm
must be accompanied by a certificate of
the reference material
whereas a reference material is
accompanied by a product information
sheet
also note that my reference material is
a quality gate
it can also be used as a general term to
encompass all quality crates within the
pyramid
the quality requirements for the last
two levels
are defined by each individual vendor
rather than the bio-national government
or iso
for the analytical standard grade which
merck offers
the product is manufactured within the
general iso 9001 quality system
requirement
not specific to just reference materials
a certificate of analysis is provided
with an analytical standard
it contains information such as product
identity
purity and an expiration date
generally the level of certification
varies from vendor to vendor
the lowest level is the research grade
or research chemical
it may or may not come with a
certificate of analysis
the data offered is not sufficient to
use the product as a reference material
especially for quantitative applications
where high accuracy is critical
reference material producers there's an
international standard
and three iso guides that support the
production
and certification of reference materials
to ensure
that the quality of the reference
material meets the requirements
of the end users the international
standard the iso 17034
the latest edition from 2017
outlines the general requirements to be
met by a reference material producer to
show competence
the crm should be characterized by a
methodologically valid procedure
should be accompanied by a certificate
where the certified value
of the specified property is dated
including
uncertainties and metrological
traceability
the iso is a worldwide federation of
national standard bodies
the work of preparing international
standards is normally carried out
through iso technical committees this
ensures that the cm
issued in the united states is produced
to follow the same rules regarding
documentation
certification and labeling as a product
being produced in germany or india
besides the iso 17034 guideline
three more guidelines give specific
information
about the production and certification
of reference materials
and support the iso 17034 to ensure
that the quality of the reference meets
the requirements of the end user
there's the isoguide 35 it provides more
specific guidance on technical issues
and explains the concepts of processes
such as the assessment of homogeneity
stability
and characterization for the
certification of reference materials
second is the isoguide 31 it describes
the contents of certificates for crms
and of accompanying documents for other
reference materials
and last is the isoguide 30. it contains
terms and definitions related to
reference materials
now i would like to go into more details
regarding the requirements
of a cm which have to be outlined in the
certificate
of the reference material
every commercial certified reference
material should come
with a reference material certificate
this is the most critical portion of any
crm in all honesty when you purchase
a reference standard you aren't really
paying for the small quantity
of material in the vial or ample you are
paying for the certification
documented on the certificate of
analysis
on the next slides i want to show you
the relevant information
on a reference material certificate for
a thc cannabinoid mix
required by the iso 17034
the iso guideline 31 lists all of the
features which have to be included in
the certificate
here on the right side there's a list of
requirements
which have to break down in the
reference material certificate
the certified property values and the
uncertainties are the facts you surely
want to recognize
first on a certificate we do put this
information on the first page
the property values in our case the
concentrations
is a combined value and is calculated on
the actual measured mass
the purity factor of the analyte the
measured mass of the solution and the
density of the pure diluent
the property values have to report with
a combined
uncertainty which covers all
contribution
which add to an uncertainty balance
during the whole certification process
in our case we calculate contributions
from the purity factor
the material density which includes a
homogeneity study
the balance and the weighing technique
as well as contribution from ampolin
and our stability tests easygod 31 also
requires
that the coa states the coverage
interval was a specified
level of confidence in our case we have
a 95
confidence interval using the coverage
vector of k
equals two this is mostly used for
symmetric distributions
now some words about purity purity does
not include just chromographic purity
alone
but also residual solvents water and
trace inorganics
from the manufacturing and our
purification process
all are required to be measured to
obtain a complete picture of
chromatographic
and non-chromatographic impurities in
the material
for our cannabinoid mixes we use the
method
of mass balance to determine all
impurities
each technique includes its own
validated method for carrying out one
part of the full characterization
the formula below shows how all the
results from the different testing
techniques are taken together to
generate the purity factor
for assigning the final purity
iso 17034 requires a cm producer to
provide
evidence of the methodological
traceability of the certified value to a
stated reference
to an si unit via a primary reference
material
for our cannabinoid mix we state the
traceability
of the certified gravimetrically
prepared standard
via the less traceable weight to the si
unit of kilogram
additionally each neat material has been
analyzed and characterized via mass
balance approach
which links via iso 17025 accredited
validated methods for example carl
fischer
rester solvents or los angeles via
primary reference material to the sr
unit of coulomb
mole per kilogram this is a graphic
to show to you how the different
traceabilities from the single
components and the mixture derive
now why is traceability so important
it ensures for you as a user of crms
that values you are getting from your
analysis using cms as calibration
standards can be compared
even if they are made at different times
at different places
by different people or by using
different equipment
the periodicity of validity also
known as shelf life or expiry date and
the storage information
can be found on the first page of this
reference material certificate
from our cannabinoid mix the data
derived from stability studies
iso 17034 requests short-term and
long-term stability studies
the short-term studies leading to the
re-test date
the long-term studies and various
temperature leading to the storage
temperature
and shipping information within the
certificate
we also provide more explicit
information about our stability studies
regarding our retest date we perform
after the release of the product
to the market further stability stubbles
in tight intervals
which also gives us the ability to react
on non-predictable stability issues
or even extend the retest date
homogeneity studies are another
requirement of the iso17034
and is thoroughly described in the
isoguide 35
it ensures that the certified
concentrations
is within the uncertainty limits
throughout this batch
from the first till the last temple
after preparation of the solution it is
mixed for a certain amount of time to
ensure maximum homogeneity
then the whole batch is ampled and
samples are taken
over the whole lot and analyzed for the
verified concentration
the relative standard deviation criteria
of less than five percent have to be met
and this is outlined on the certificate
of analysis
now there are some more mandatory
information which have to be put
on the certified so under certificate of
the reference material which i want to
show you now
there is the title of the document
the name of the cam which is in our case
the thc cannabinoid mixture
iii a unique identifier of the crm
we use our catalog number and the
solution lot number
its intended use a minimum sample size
instruction for handling and use
as well as the page number
and the total number of pages the
document version
the description of the material
the name and function of the material
producers approving officer
and name and contact details of the
reference material producer
now what are the critical attributes you
should look
in selecting the reference material most
appropriate for your specific
application
let's have a look at the slide for
instrument qualifications and
calibrations
establishing and maintaining
traceability is critical
your reference material should help you
achieve this
in daily routine system suitability
applications it might be important to
qualify something
that is practical and easy to use yet
reliable and cost effective for everyday
use
in method validation it's critical to
use highly accurate and precise
materials to show that your method
is accurate and precise for identity and
screening purposes
you need materials with proven
authenticity and
identity for quantitation essays
or stability assessment stable and
accurate reference materials are needed
so which grade of reference material
should you use for each of these test
types
well this chart helps to answer that
question
instrument qualifications and
calibrations these might be
annual qualifications or routine
calibrations
higher order and companion standards are
most useful here to provide traceability
and prove the system is performing
accurately
they give the traceability that's
required to these eye units
which are required by the iso7025
cms also provide this necessary
traceability
and uncertainty needed for these tests
for routine calibration and system
suitability one can use a higher order
standard
but it may be more practical to use a
crm
a reference material or analytical
standard could be used
if it's suitably qualified for the
specific test
just be sure to establish qualification
of the reference material
or analytical standard to a cm before
using it
for non-quantitative tests especially
reference material or analytical
standards
may be adequate method validation
according to the respect of testing in
this positive you prove that your method
is accurate and precise
it's really important to use a crm or a
higher order standard to establish the
method validity
reference materials are useful when crms
are not available
identity tests these tests require
authentic substance for comparison
and the laboratory could use any of the
equality crates listed
as ss this is a quantitative test
therefore
it's important to ensure primary
standard a crm or a qualified reference
material is used
for stability and routine quality
control one can use higher order
materials
but it's more practical and acceptable
to use crms
if reference materials or analytical
standards are used
they have to be qualified for their use
in this specific
target method the major take-home point
here is now
fit for purpose decisions can depend on
several factors
from regulatory requirements
availability
and type of testing application to level
of accuracy
and sample metrics the information
you have seen here today is nicely
summarized on our website
as shown here this quality web page
covers all the topics important to a
laboratory's reference material buying
decision
from si units of measure the reference
material quality grades and metrological
traceabilities
key to cos and how to determine the best
fit for purpose reference material
the web link is shown in the bottom
right of the slide
i now like to thank my colleagues across
our four reference material
manufacturing sites for their
contribution
to today's presentation our four sites
include
two in the united states broad rock in
texas
and laramie in wyoming along with
books in switzerland and darmstadt in
germany
and thank you for your time and
attention
welcome to kenner lab my name is rafael
today i'll be sharing some tips and
tricks for preparing instrument
calibration standards
i hope you find this information
informative and with these
tips and tricks you continue to advance
your laboratory productivity
by reducing unnecessary downtime
tips and tricks when preparing standards
for analytical instrumentation
calibration
first determine which standards are
required for your method
second determine what's going to be your
working calibration range
before cracking open your crm vials
read the certificate of analysis to
ensure
that you follow the recommended analyte
specific instructions
specific instructions may include
storage and handling
temperatures and conditions we recommend
preparing standards
using volumetric or govermetrically to
ensure the highest level of accuracy
and batch to batch consistency if
necessary
be particularly mindful that some
analytes are light sensitive
and their concentrations may change over
time if not handled in the appropriate
graph
glassware some analytes may adhere
the absorption to the walls of the
pipette tips glassware or sample vials
this is especially important when
working at low concentration levels
ppb and below for this reason
it is very important to follow the
recommended handling conditions in the
certificate of analysis
it is also important to not introduce
additional variables or contaminants
into your standards to minimize this
always use the correct grade solvent for
extractions
and dilutions utilizing an incorrect or
lower
grade solvent may yield at these
additional unwanted bonus peaks in your
chromatography
or provide a high instrument baseline
background
which may affect your methods
sensitivity
after you have ensured that you have the
required method analytes
solvents glassware and sample handling
labware
you are on your way to generate generate
calibration
standards if you're starting with the
solid material
it may be necessary to sonicate the
standard solution
to ensure that maximum solubility is
achieved
let's not forget that vial caps are very
important
it is very important to select an
autosampler vial cap
that is inert and would withstand
multiple injections
if this is part of your method
requirements keep in mind that some
other sampler vial caps may have a
pre-slit
which may cause sample or standard
evaporation over time
in this example we can see the effects
of analyte absorption onto vials
surfaces
the calibration curve on the left was
generated with low absorption glass
vials
the calibration curve on the right was
generated
with regular glass vials as you can see
quantitation will probably
be challenging utilizing the calibration
curve on the right
the point here is that not all vials are
created equal
use the right vial for your particular
analysis
when preparing your calibration
standards you must consider
whether solving standards are adequate
for your particular analysis
sometimes there are matrix interferences
that can cause signal suppression
or signal enhancements and therefore a
matrix match calibration standard
may be more suitable in this particular
case
to ensure adequate quantitation of the
analyte
also not all solvents may respond the
same
so you may want to explore a few options
during your method development process
how long are your calibration standards
good for
that's a very good question and the
answer to that is it depends
you will want to monitor the standard
response over time
and determine how long they are stable
for under your
current laboratory conditions utilizing
the right solvent
glassware and avoiding harsh conditions
will ensure that your standards last as
long as possible
thanks so much for attending today's
event we hope that these tips and tricks
will allow you to continue producing the
excellent results
you are accustomed to achieving in your
daily laboratory workflows
for additional details on cannabis
related analysis and workflows
please visit our site at
sigmaaldrich.com
cannabis thanks